thank you
well it is wonderful to be here
and I always look forward to an
opportunity to speak to some of our top
businesses across the country who are
hiring people investing in America
making the economy run and many of you
I've had a chance to interact with
before as you know oftentimes when I do
something like this I want to spend more
time answering questions and having a
conversation than giving any formal
remarks let me just provide a little bit
of an introduction obviously over the
last couple of months most of the oxygen
in this town has be been consumed with
two things one the government shutdown
and the possibility of default that was
ultimately resolved and the second has
been the rollout of the Affordable Care
Act and the fact that my websites not
working the way it's supposed to and
it's entirely legitimate that those have
been issues of great concern the impact
of the shutdown and the threat of
default I think not only did some
significant damage to the economy at a
time when we didn't need self-inflicted
wounds but it also spoke to some larger
problems we've seen here in Washington
and the sense of dysfunction and the
seeming incapacity of both parties in
Congress to work together to advance an
agenda that's going to help us grow with
respect to the Affordable Care Act and I
think people are legitimately concerned
because we have a major problem with
health care in this country 41 million
people without health insurance a lot of
people underinsured and once again how
we fix a health care system that's been
broken for too many people for too long
I think ends up speaking to how much
confidence we have in government and
whether we still have the capacity
collectively to bring about changes that
are going to be
good for our economy good for our
businesses good for the American people
I do want to say though that beyond the
headlines we have made real progress in
the economy and sometimes that hasn't
gotten enough attention some of the
tough decisions that we made early on
have paid off decision that's that
helped us not only recover from a crisis
but begin to lay a stronger foundation
for future growth we refocused on
manufacturing exports and today our
businesses sell more goods and services
made in America than ever before around
the world after a decade of shedding
jobs our manufacturing sector has now
added about half a million new jobs and
it's led by an American auto industry
that has come roaring back after decades
of decline we decided to reverse our
dependence on foreign oil and today we
generate more renewable energy than ever
before and more natural gas than anybody
in the world and for the first time in
nearly 20 years America now produces
more of our own oil than we buy from
other countries when I took office we
invested a fraction of what other
countries did in wireless infrastructure
and today it's up nearly 50 percent
helping companies unleash jobs
innovation and a booming app economy
that's created more than 500,000 jobs
when I took office only 5% of the
world's smartphones ran on American
operating systems today more than 80% do
and it's not just in the high-tech
economy that we're seeing progress for
example American farmers are on pace to
have one of their best years in decades
and they have consistently been able to
export more make more profits and help
restore rural economies than when we
came into office and yes we decide to
take on a broken health care system and
even though the rollout of the new
health care marketplace has been rough
to say the least about half a million
Americans are now poised to gain health
care coverage beginning January 1st
that's
after only a month of sign-up we also
have seen health care costs growing at
the slowest rate in 50 years
employer-based health costs are growing
at about one third of the rate of a
decade ago and that has an impact on
your bottom line and after years of
trillion-dollar deficits we reigned in
spending wound down to Wars and began to
change a tax code that I believed was
too skewed towards the wealthiest among
us at the expense of the middle class in
since office since I took office we have
now cut our deficits by more than half
and it all up and businesses like yours
have created 7.8 million new jobs over
the past 44 months we've gone farther
and recovered faster than most other
advanced nations and so in a lot of ways
America is poised for a break up we are
in a good position to compete around the
world in the 21st century the question
is are we going to realize that
potential and that means that we've
still got some more work to do our stock
markets and corporate profits are
soaring but we've got to make sure that
this remains a country where everyone
who works hard can get ahead and that
means what we've still got to address
long-term unemployment we still have to
address stagnant wages and stagg
stagnant incomes and frankly we've got
to stop governing by crisis here in this
town because if it weren't for
Washington's dysfunction I think all of
us agree we'd be a lot further along the
shutdown and the threat of default
harmed our jobs market they cost our
economy about five billion dollars and
economists predict it will slow our GDP
growth this quarter and it didn't need
to happen it was self-inflicted we
should not be injuring ourselves every
few months we should be investing in
ourselves and in a sensible world that
starts with a budget that cuts what we
don't need closes wasteful loopholes and
helps us afford to invest in the things
that we know will help businesses like
yours and the economy as a whole
education infrastructure basic research
and development we would have a grand
bargain for middle
that combines tax reform with a
financing mechanism but lets us create
jobs rebuilding infrastructure that your
businesses depend on but we haven't
gotten as much take-up from the other
side as we'd like to see so far we have
the opportunity for bipartisan authority
to negotiate the best trade deals
possible
so businesses and workers can take
advantage of new markets that are
opening up around the world we haven't
seen the kind of take-up from the other
side that we'd like to see so far we've
got the opportunity to fix a broken
immigration system that strengthens our
economy and our national security the
good news here is the Senate has already
passed a bipartisan bill that economists
say would grow our economy by one point
four trillion dollars and shrink our
deficits by nearly a trillion dollars
over the next two decades you wouldn't
turn down a deal that good and Congress
shouldn't either so I'm hoping that
Speaker Boehner and the House of
Representatives can still work with us
to get that done and we need to be going
all out to prepare our kids and our
workers for the demands of a 21st
century economy I've proposed giving
every child an early started success by
making high quality preschool available
to every four-year-old in America we
know that you get more bang for the buck
when it comes to early childhood
education than just about anything else
and you've got great examples around the
country it's often times in red states
that are doing just that we need to make
that same investment we're working to
bring down the costs of a college degree
so more young people can get a higher
education and one thing that I'm very
excited about and this has been a good
example of a public-private partnership
is the idea of redesigning our high
schools to make sure that more young
people get hands-on training and develop
the skills that they need particularly
in math science and engineering that
businesses are looking for and in fact
today we're announcing a competitive
grant program that will encourage more
high schools to partner with colleges
and local businesses to better prepare
our kids for college or a career and in
December I'll be bringing together
college presidents and other leaders to
figure out ways to help more low-income
students attend and succeed in college
so
just to sum up my basic message is this
we know what the challenges are we know
what the solutions are some of them are
tough but what's holding us back is not
a lack of good policy ideas or even what
used to be considered good bipartisan
policy ideas we just have to break
through the stubborn cycle of crisis
politics and start working together more
obstruction more brinksmanship won't
help anybody
it doesn't help folks politically my
understanding is nobody in this towns
doing particularly well at the moment
when it comes to the opinions of the
American people but it certainly doesn't
help anybody economically on many of the
issues I think you and I would agree and
I want you to know that I'm rooting for
your success and I look forward to
making sure that we are able in the
remaining three years that I'm president
to work together to not only improve the
business climate but also improve the
prospects for Americans all across the
country who have been treading water
feel like they're losing ground are
anxious about the future and their
children's futures but I think are still
hopeful and still possess that
fundamental American optimism if they
see leadership working across the board
on their behalf that I'm confident that
we can make enormous progress so with
that while we get Jerry up here and I'll
start answering his questions I hope you
had some input if he starts asking me
about what happened to the Kansas City
Chiefs the I'm not sure I have a good
answer for that one
Thank You mr. president
let me start by thanking you officially
for joining us today I think you
probably see a lot of familiar faces out
there most friendly most of them and I
would also note that you're getting here
a little late Congressman Paul Ryan is
coming later he's going to get here a
little early so a few guys overlap a
little bit maybe we could just get some
problem solve right here let's do it
let's do it it's your chance we have
talked amongst ourselves I've tried to
sort of take the the sense of the room
and so I'm going to try to reflect some
of the conversations that have been
going on here in the questions I'm going
to ask you you'll not be stunned that
I'm gonna ask you about healthcare first
you indicated there and you've indicated
publicly quite clearly that the rollout
has been difficult what do you think
you've learned from this experience
about the government's ability to do
this sort of thing about the law itself
about your own administration well there
are a couple of things number one is
that this has been a big problem for a
very long time and so it was always
going to be challenging not just to pass
a law but also to implement it there's a
reason why despite a century of talking
about it nobody had been able to
successfully try to deal with some of
the underlying problems in in the health
care system the good news is that many
of the elements of the Affordable Care
Act are already in place and are working
exactly the way they're supposed to so
making sure that consumers who have you
know employer-based health insurance are
getting a better deal and that are
protected from some of the fine print
that left them in the lurch when they
actually got sick that's in place making
sure that young people under the age of
26 can stay on their parents plan that's
helped three million children already
that's making a difference helping
seniors to get better prescription drug
prices that's already helped millions of
seniors and billions of dollars in
savings rebates for people who see
insurance companies who are not spending
enough on
actual care more on administrative costs
or profits they're getting rebates they
may not know it's the Affordable Care
Act that's given them rebates but it's
happening so there were a number of
things that were already in place over
the last three years that got
implemented effectively the other thing
that hasn't been talked about a lot is
cost there was a lot of skepticism when
we passed the Affordable Care Act that
we were going to be given a lot of
people care but we weren't doing
anything about the underlying costs and
in fact over the last three years we
have seen health care costs grow at the
slowest pace in 50 years and that
affects the bottom lines of everybody
here and there are a lot of smart
delivery system reforms that slowly
across the system are being implemented
and they're making a big difference and
that's saving us money that's why by the
way some of the projections that in
terms of what the Affordable Care Act
would do to deficits have actually
proved even better than we had
originally expected what I have learned
though with respect to setting up these
marketplaces which are essentially
mechanisms were people who are currently
in the individual market or don't have
health insurance at all can join
together shop and insurance companies
will compete for their business
setting those things up is very
challenging just mechanically the good
news is that choice and competition has
actually worked and insurers came in
with bids that were even lower than
people expected about 16 percent lower
than had originally been projected the
challenge has been just making sure that
consumers are actually able to get on a
website see those choices and shop and I
think that we probably underestimated
the complexities of building out a
website that needed to work the way it
should there is a larger problem that I
probably speak personally but also as
the administration could have identified
earlier and that is the way the Fed
government does procurement and does IT
is just generally not very efficient
in fact there's probably no bigger gap
between the private sector and the
public sector than IT and we've seen
that in for example the VA and the
Department of Defense trying to deal
with electronic medical records for our
servicemen as they move into civilian
life most of that stuff's still done on
paper we've spent billions of dollars
I'm not saying we as in my
administration I mean we've now had
about a decade of experimentation spend
billions of dollars and it's still not
working the way it should so what we
probably needed to do on the front end
was to blow up how we procure for IT the
especially onyx system is complicated we
did not do that successfully now we are
getting it fixed but it would have been
better to do it on the front end rather
than the back end and the last point
I'll make is that you know in terms of
expectation setting yeah there's no
doubt that in an environment in which we
had to fight tooth and nail to get this
past it ended up being passed on a bite
on a partisan basis not for lack of
trying because I met with an awful lot
of Republicans try to get them all to go
along but because there was just
ideological resistance to the idea of
dealing with the uninsured and people
with pre-existing conditions you know
there was a there was a price to that
and it was that what was already going
to be hard was operating within a very
difficult political environment and we
should have anticipated that that would
create a rockier rollout then if
Democrats and Republicans were both
invested in success one of the problems
we've had is one side of Capitol Hill is
invested in failure and and that makes I
think the the kind of iterative process
of fixing glitches as they come up and
fine-tuning the law more challenging but
I'm optimistic
we can get it fixed well that's the
question I was gonna ask next is it
possible you've lost enough time here
and enough potential customers in the
exchanges that you're not going to reach
the critical mass of signups that you
need to make the marketplace work is
that a danger that you have to worry
about right now well it's it's something
that we have to pay attention to but
keep in mind that this model of
marketplaces was based on what was done
in Massachusetts and the experience in
Massachusetts was that in the first
month a hundred and fifty three or sixty
three people signed up out of an
ultimate 36,000 it was less than one
percent signed up in that first month
partly because buying the insurance is a
complicated process for a lot of people
when they have more choices it means
that they're gonna take more time
there's no doubt that we've lost some
time but the website's getting better
each week by the end of this month it
will be functioning for the majority of
people who are using it they'll be able
to shop to see what their choices are
the prices are good the prices are not
changing for during the open enrollment
period that goes out until March and so
I think that we're gonna have time to
catch up what's also been expressed as a
concern is the mix of people that sign
up so we might end up you know having
millions of people sign up they're happy
with their new coverage but we've got
more people who are older more likely to
get sick than younger and healthier
we've got to monitor that carefully we
always anticipated though that younger
folks would be the last folks in just
because you know it's been a while since
you and I were young but as I recall you
don't think that you're gonna get sick
you know at that time so look I am
confident that the model that we've
built which works off of the existing
private insurance system is one that
will succeed we are gonna have to a fix
the website so everybody
feels confident about that we're going
to have to obviously remark it and
rebrand and that will be challenging in
this political environment but keep in
mind in in the first month we also had
12 million people visit the site the
demand is there there are 41 million
people who have helped don't have health
insurance the folks in the individual
market many of them are going to get a
much better deal in the marketplaces and
so we've just got to keep on improving
the customer experience and make sure
that we're fending off efforts not to
fix the problem because if somebody
wants to help us fix it I'm all game but
fending off efforts to completely
undermine let me turn the economy the
broader economy probably the the
predominant concern of people in this
room we seem to be stuck in an economic
growth pattern of okay but not great
growth your friend Larry Summers was
here earlier today and said essentially
the problem are one of the problems is
that the system can't do two things at
once it can't cut deficits and spur
growth it needs to do one of the other
right now it needs to spur growth should
not worry so much about deficits do you
agree and if you do agree how do you
make that happen you know actually Larry
and I and most of my economic team in
fact all my economic team have
consistently maintained that there is a
way to reconcile the concerns about debt
and deficits with the concerns about
growth what we know is is that our our
fiscal problems are not short term
deficits our discretionary budget that
portion of the federal budget that isn't
defense or Social Security or Medicare
or Medicaid the entitlement programs is
its smallest level in my lifetime price
since Dwight Eisenhower
we are not lavishly spending on a whole
bunch of social programs out there and
in many ways a lot of these programs
have become more efficient and pretty
effective defense
we spent a lot from 2001 to 2011 but
generally we are stabilizing and the
Pentagon working with me have come up
with plans that allow us to meet our
security needs while still bringing down
some of the costs of of defense
particularly after having ended the war
in Iraq and on the brink of ending of
the war in Afghanistan so when we talk
about our deficit and debt problems it
is almost entirely healthcare costs you
you eliminate the the the Delta but the
difference between what we spend on
healthcare and what every other country
advanced industrialized nation spends on
health care and that's our long-term
debt and if we're able to bend the cost
curve we help solve the problem now one
way to do that is just to make health
care cheaper overall that's I think the
best way to do it and that's what we've
been doing through some of the measures
in the Affordable Care Act there are
some other provisions that we could take
that would maintain our commitment to
seniors Medicare Social Security the
disabled and Medicaid while still
reducing very modestly the cost of those
programs if we do those things that
solves our real fiscal problem and we
could take some of that money very
modest portion on the front end and
invest in infrastructure that puts
people back to work it improve our
research and development so the idea
would be do some things in the short
term that focus on growth do some things
in the long term the deal with the long
term debt that's what my budget reflects
that's what a multiple series of
negotiations with John Boehner you know
talked about the so-called grand bargain
we couldn't quite get there in the end
mainly because Republicans had a great
deal of difficulty with the idea of
putting in more revenue to balance out
some of the changes that were made on
entitlements I would guess a lot of
people in this room would say another
way to make some of those things happen
would be to fix the corporate tax code
that everybody agrees is a mess you got
some companies that pay way too much
compared to the international
competitors some companies don't pay at
all it's not a good system it's not an
efficient system everybody agrees but it
doesn't ever seem to change can you make
a change and and can you do something
about repatriation of the US assets
overseas well here's the good news is
that both my administration and
Republicans have talked about corporate
tax reform and Paul Ryan who's going to
be coming after me has said he's
interested in corporate tax reform and
we've reached out to him and we've said
let's get to work we put forward a very
specific set of proposals that would
lower the corporate tax rate broaden the
base close some loopholes and in terms
of international companies and
competitiveness what we've said is
rather than a whole bunch of tangled
laws that incentivize folks to keep
money overseas let's have a modest but
clear global minimum tax get rid of some
of the huge fluctuations that people
experience it will save companies money
make them more competitive and in terms
of transitioning to that system actually
allows some people to bring back money
and in a one-time way help us finance
infrastructure and some other projects
that need to get done
I don't expect Republicans to adopt
exactly the proposal that we've put
forward but there's not that much
separation between what Democrats are
talking about I know
chairman Max Baucus put out something
today the chairman of the Finance
Committee what Dave camp over in the
house has talked about this should be
bridgeable the one thing I would caution
is and I've said this to the Business
Roundtable and other corporate leaders
who have I've talked to people like the
idea of corporate tax reform in
in practice if you want to make the
corporate tax reform deficit-neutral
right then you actually have to close
some loopholes and people like the idea
of a simpler tax system until it's their
particular loophole that's about to get
closed and what we can't afford to do is
to keep all the loopholes that are
currently in place and lower the
corporate tax rate we would then blow
another hold the deficit that would have
to be filled and what I'm not willing to
do is to have higher rates on the middle
class in order to pay for that some of
the CEOs here had a working group
earlier today the the the the mission of
which was to address the question of how
do you stay competitive interestingly at
least to me their first priority first
priority was this immigration reform the
US needs immigration reform to retain
talented workers educated in the US and
attract talent to the u.s. immigration
reform could provide an instant jolt to
the US economy which we need I know you
agree with that statement but it's hard
to see that happening right now you've
got the Senate off on one track it's
passed a comprehensive bill the house
won't even agree to take up Democrats
want to do comprehensive reform
Republicans want to do step-by-step
reform it's a poisonous political
atmosphere can you make it happen yeah I
am actually optimistic that we're going
to get this done
i'ma but I am a congenital optimist I
would have to be a I'm named Barack
Obama I ran for president and won and
won twice so look
keep in mind first of all that what the
CEOs here said is absolutely right
this is a boost to our economy
everywhere I go I meet with
entrepreneurs and CEOs who say I've got
you know these terrific folks they just
graduated from Cal Tech or MIT or
Stanford they're ready to do business
here some of them have these amazing new
ideas that we think we can commercialize
but
they're being dragged back to their home
countries not because they want to go
but because the immigration system
doesn't work the good news is that the
Senate bill was a bipartisan bill and we
know what the component parts of this
are we've got to have strong border
security we've got to have better
enforcement of existing laws we've got
to make sure that we have a legal
immigration system that doesn't cause
people to sit in the queue for five
years 10 years 15 years in some cases 20
years we should want to immediately say
to young people who we've helped to
educate in this country you want to stay
we want you here and we do have to deal
with about 11 million folks who are in
this country most of them just seeking
opportunity they did break the law by
coming here or overstaying their visa
and they've got to earn their way out of
the shadows pay a fine learn English get
to the back of the line pay their back
taxes but giving them a mechanism
whereby they can get right by by our
society and that's reflected in the
Senate bill now I actually think that
there are a number of House Republicans
including Paul Ryan I think if you ask
him about it
who agree with that they're suspicious
of comprehensive bills but you know what
if they want to chop that thing up into
five pieces as long as all five pieces
get done I don't care what it looks like
as long as it's actually delivering on
those core values that we talked about
Democrats have been pretty suspicious
that all five pieces well and on and and
that's the problem I mean the key is you
know what we don't want to do is simply
carve out one piece of it let's say
agricultural jobs which are important
but is easier frankly or the
high-skilled jobs that many of in your
audience here would immediately want to
do but leave behind some of the tougher
stuff
that still needs to get done we're not
going to have a situation which 11
million people are still living in the
shadows and potentially getting deported
on an ongoing basis so we're gonna have
to do it all in my conversations with
the Republicans I actually think the
divide is not that wide so what we just
have to do is find a pathway where
Republicans in the House in particular
feel comfortable enough about process
that they can go ahead and meet us
this by the way Jerry I think is a good
example of something that's been
striking me about our politics for a
while
when you go to other countries the
political divisions are so much more
stark and wider here in America the
difference between Democrats and
Republicans
we're fighting inside the 40-yard line
maybe you fooled most people in that in
the last few months I'd say no no but
but well no no no the the I would
distinguish between the the rhetoric and
the tactics versus the ideological
differences and in most countries you've
got people call me a socialist sometimes
but no you got to meet real socialists
you'll have a sense of what a what a
socialist is you know the I mean I'm
talking about lowering the corporate tax
rate my health care reform is based on
the the private marketplace stock market
is looking pretty good last time I
checked and you know it is true that I'm
concerned about growing inequality in
our system but nobody questions the
efficacy of a market economies in terms
of producing wealth and innovation and
keeping us competitive on the flip side
you know most Republicans even even the
tea party you have one of my favorite
signs during the campaign was folks
hoisting a signed government's key key
keep your hands off my Medicare think
about that the you know ideologically
they did not like the idea of the
federal government and yet they felt
very protective about the basic social
safety net that had been structured so
my simple point is this if we can get
beyond the tactical advantages that
parties perceive in painting folks as
extreme and trying to keep an eye on the
next election and for a while at least
just focus on governing then the there
is probably 70% overlap on a whole range
of issues a lot of Republicans want to
get infrastructure done just like I do a
lot of them believe in basic research
just like I do a lot of them want to
reform entitlements to make sure that
they're affordable for the next
generation so do I a lot of them say
they want to reform our tax system so do
I there are going to be differences on
the details and those details matter and
I'll fight very hard for them but we
shouldn't think that somehow the reason
we've got these problems is because our
policy differences are so great well the
details were obviously important enough
to shut down the government just a
couple of weeks ago and everybody knows
we're headed back toward showdowns again
January budget February debt ceiling
Jack Lew was here earlier your Treasury
secretary and said he thought maybe the
system crossed the threshold in October
and has realized it doesn't want to go
back and do that again are you confident
it's not going to go back and do that
again and by the way the OECD the
Organization of Economic Cooperation
Development suggested today that the
u.s. just get rid of the debt ceiling
entirely would you be in favor of that I
think that the way our system is set up
is like a loaded gun and once people
thought we can get leverage on policy
disputes
by threatening default that was an
extraordinarily dangerous precedent and
that's a principle that I had to adhere
to not just for me but for the next
president that you're not going to be
able to threaten the entire US or world
economy simply because you disagree with
me about a health care bill I'd like to
believe that the Republicans recognize
that was not a good strategy and we're
probably better off with a system in
which that threat is not there on a
perpetual basis I do not foresee what we
saw in October being repeated in January
but the broader point is one that I
think all of us have to take to heart we
have to be able to disagree on policy
issues without resorting to the kinds of
extreme tactics that end up hurting all
of us and that's been my main
disagreement with a lot of my Republican
friends and frankly the American people
agree with that that they don't expect
us to March and lockstep there's a
reason why we got to parties in this
country they do expect that we are
constantly thinking about how are we
making sure they can find a job that
pays well that their kids can go to
college and afford it that we are
growing and competitive that you know we
are dealing with our fiscal position in
a sensible way and and if we keep them
in mind consistently then I think we're
going to be successful I want one thing
that you've got some international CEOs
here and I think they'll confirm this
when I travel what's striking to me is
people around the world think we've got
a really good hand you just take the
example of energy they say America is
poised to change our geopolitics
entirely because of the advances we've
made an oil production natural gas
production
it means manufacturing here is much more
attractive than it used to be that's a
huge competitive advantage we've got
the most productive workers just about
in the world and we our workers have
become more and more productive and a
lot of companies look at that and say we
wish we had workers who were able to
operate the way these folks do our
university systems our research Mecca
you know infrastructure all those things
are the envy of the world and one of the
great things about America sometimes we
get worried that we're losing traction
and the sky is falling and back in the
80s Japan was about to take over and
then China and obviously before that the
Soviet Union and we usually come out
okay because we change and we adapt I
just want everybody to remember that
we're in a very strong position to
compete as long as our political system
functions it doesn't have to be
outstanding this is sort of like Winston
Churchill - cheers for democracy and you
know it does it's always gonna be messy
but it's got a function better than it
has I mean the redzone on the clock here
but let me I didn't ask about a question
about international affairs you
mentioned the world and in the US
position in it there's the possibility
this week of an agreement with Iran a
preliminary limited agreement in which
they would freeze some of their nuclear
activities in return for some relief on
sanctions you're Israeli friends have
been arguing along with some some of
your uh some of your friends as well as
your foes in Congress that if you give
the Iranian regime any relief on
sanctions the sanctions regime will fall
apart countries that don't want to be
there and the first place will head for
the exits it'll all come apart and
that's the danger of what you're
negotiating right now I know you talked
to some senators about this very topic
today is there going to be a deal and
why can you ease sanctions without
having them fall apart well just by way
of background when I came into office we
had a trade embargo the US had done some
things unilaterally we did not have a
strong enforceable international
mechanism to really put the squeeze on
Iran
around its nuclear program despite the
fact that it violated a range of UN and
non-proliferation treaty requirements so
we built we constructed with the help of
Congress the strongest sanctions regime
ever and it has put a bite on the
Iranian economy they have seen a 5
percent contraction last year in their
economy it's projected to be contraction
this year and in part because the
sanctions have been so effective we were
able to get Iran to seriously come to
the table and look at how are they going
to give assurances to the international
community that they are in fact not
pursuing a nuclear weapons program I
don't know if we'll be able to close a
deal this week or next week we have been
very firm with the Iranians even on the
interim deal about what we expect and
you know some of the reporting out there
has been somewhat inaccurate
understandably because the p5 plus 1 the
members of the permanent members of the
Security Council in addition to and and
Germany as well have kept the
negotiations fairly tight but the
essence of the deal would be that they
would halt advances on their nuclear
program they would roll back some
elements that get them closer to what we
call breakout capacity where they can
run for a weapon before the
international community has a chance to
react that they would subject themselves
to more vigorous inspections even than
the ones that are currently there in
some cases daily inspections in return
what we would do would be to open up the
spigot a little bit for a very modest
amount of relief that is entirely
subject to reinstatement if in fact they
violated any part of this early
agreement and it would purchase a period
of time let's say six months during
which
we could see if they could get to the
end state of a position where we the
Israelis in the international community
could say with confidence arounds not
pursuing a nuclear weapon now part of
the reason I have confidence that the
sanctions don't fall apart is because
we're not doing anything around the most
powerful sanctions the oil sanctions the
banking sanctions the financial services
sanctions those are the ones that have
really taken a big chunk out of the
Iranian economy
so oil production and oil sales out of
Iran have dropped by more than half
since these sanctions were put in place
they've got over a hundred billion
dollars of oil revenue that is sitting
outside of their country
the real their currency has dropped
precipitously and all those sanctions
and the architecture for them don't go
anywhere
essentially what we do is we allow them
to access a small portion of these
assets that are frozen keep in mind
though that because the oil and banking
sanctions stay in place they will
actually still be losing money even
during this six-month period relative to
the amount of oil sales they had back in
2011
so what we are what we are suggesting
both to the Israelis to members of
Congress here to the international
community but also to the Iranians is
let's look let's test the proposition
that over the next six months we can
resolve this in a diplomatic fashion
while maintaining the essential
sanctions architecture and as president
United States me maintaining all options
to prevent them from getting nuclear
weapons I think that is a test that is
worth conducting and my hope and
expectation is not that we're going to
solve all of this just this week in and
this interim phase but rather that we're
purchasing ourselves some time to see
how serious the Iranian regime might be
in re-entering membership in in the
world community and taking the the yoke
of these sanctions off off the backs of
their economy well mr. president with
that let me just thank you again for
joining us appreciate it very much
I enjoyed it thank you very much